it is tuesday time for our pet vet
segment with dr jamie ogenstein of oasis
animal hospital in henderson
dr ogenstein thanks so much we've made
it pet week here on channel 8 that means
we're focused on all things animals this
week and
we'd like to know some important tips
that you'd like to share for
people adopting a new pet for the very
first time including how to go about
introducing them to other pet members in
the household as well
that's actually a good question so one
of the things we have the most
difficulty with is introducing new cats
into a home and the best thing you can
do is to take
the new pet put it in a room by itself
own food on water on litter box close
the door
let it have a small area to it explore
it and then allow the other pets in the
home
to be able to kind of say howdy under
the door and then
after a week or so you can move it into
another room and then they get to go in
the older pets go in and explore that
room
get the new smells cat gets a new room
to explore
that way there's a little bit of a time
change or a shift in allowing them to
actually explore and get to know each
other
always taking time never force it don't
try to hold
one and force them to say hi to each
other that's never going to go well
especially between cats and dogs
[Laughter]
very good point okay and with dogs do
you just kind of take them outside and
let them you know
do their thing well best thing if their
older pets
put them on a leash and have two
different people one controlling each
pit so you can kind of see what their
responses are going to be
puppies are a little different puppies
are generally going to be kind of really
rambunctious
older pets can get a little bit you know
off-put by that so
best thing is to have the older pet or
if it's two adult dogs too adult dogs on
both on leashes so you can have control
over them if there's a problem
wonderful advice thank you dr ogenstein
let's address
pet insurance we know there's all sorts
out there you say it's becoming a big
thing can you please elaborate on that
and
in your experience what does it do best
at covering
well there's different oh gosh there's
so many different plans out there
um they're definitely becoming more
popular not
20 years ago hardly anybody had it now
more and more people do have it and it's
a good thing to have
if anything happens to your pet you'll
be glad you had it
it doesn't cover everything some of them
do have caps on what they cover
but a lot of them you can get these
plans that will cover routine
maintenance vaccines spaying neutering
dentals
if anything catastrophic happens that's
when they are the most advantageous
so do your due diligence there's a bunch
of companies out there that offer
good policies but they do work different
than human medicine human
insurance where in human medicine you go
in they cover so much and then you pay
your deductible
veterinary insurance is a little
different you're going to pay the bill
and then send it off to the insurance
company they're going to reimburse you
for whatever they're going to pay
got it okay and along those lines dr
augenstein what
is an emergency with your pet what can
weight and what needs to be seen
immediately
if you've got an animal who is in
respiratory distress
that is an emergency that is a true
emergency needs to be seen right away
if you've got a pet that uh if you look
at their mucous membrane so
look at the gums if they're white or
blue you have a medical emergency you
need to get them seen right away
if you've got an animal who cannot
urinate
and they're straining straining
straining to urinate that is a medical
emergency
we call those blocked toms if it's a
male cat that's the most common it
happens to
those are true medical emergencies and
if you've got a dog
normally large breed dogs and their
abdomen is distended
and tight and could have what we call a
bloat
that is also a true medical emergency
needs to be seen immediately
our wine runner had that years back and
luckily we got her in quick enough
so she was okay all right thank you so
much for your time dr ogenstein we look
forward to seeing you in about two weeks
in the meantime be safe and be well
thank you
thank you